over the course of the series John Wick
trades coins for weapons Medical Care
lodging drinks and favors in the first
film the gold coin represents access the
audience's invitation to the secret
underworld but trying to determine the
monetary value of a hi table coin is
futile coins are not about wealth
they're about respect in the words of
bira who oversees minting the coins and
was introduced in chapter 3 this coin of
course it does not rep represent the
monetary value it represents the
Commerce of relationships astute viewers
will note that when offered no one in
the series has yet turned down a coin or
refused to perform a favor for another
member of their society in exchange for
one in a behind the scenes featurette
John Wick producer and co-director David
Leech refers to coins as tokens of
membership